ravi de vous retrouver sur lcp public
sénat pour une nouvelle édition d'
europe hebdo nous sommes comme toujours
au coeur du parlement européen à
bruxelles
ils sont les plus nombreux parmi les
députés européens français 23 élus du
front national qui siège depuis les
élections européennes de mai dernier
mais quelle est leur vrai pouvoir ils
n'ont pas de groupe politique une simple
étiquette de non-inscrits ont-ils les
moyens de peser sur les institutions
qu'ils pourfendent c'est l'objet de
notre enquête que vous verrez dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission mais
d'abord la question européenne de la
semaine le méga plan proposé par jean
claude juncker pour sauver la croissance
européenne at il de l'avenir
est ce un plan miracle ou un mirage
réponse en images
c'est le cadeau de noël de jean claude
juncker aux citoyens européens un plan
de 315 milliards d'euros pour relancer
l'économie du continent
en panne de croissance et
d'investissement le président de la
commission rêve de grand projet pour
faire redémarrer l'activité en europe
des transports à grande vitesse des
éoliennes high tech des initiatives
numériques pour faire contrepoids aux
géants asiatiques et américains oui mais
tous venaient ce message aux citoyens
européens et aussi au reste du monde
l'europe est de retour aux avions et le
pecq l'argent ne tombera pas du ciel
l'union européenne mettra sur la table
seulement 21 milliards d'euros pour le
reste pas de cash seulement un pari sur
l'investissement privé qui viendrait
compléter l'argent garantie par
bruxelles pour un euro public la
corruption en attend jusqu'à 15 euros
venus du privé
autrement dit elles miss peu et joue
gros mais si jean claude juncker le sait
bien
la confiance ne se décrète pas il espère
que son plan permettra de créer plus
d'un million d'emplois dans les trois
ans alors miracle ou mirage qui veut
croire au père noël
et pour commenter l'actualité européenne
de la semaine nous accueillons un député
français marc joulaud bonjour vous êtes
nouvel élu ici à bruxelles vous avez été
élu en mai dernier pour la france où
siéger sous les couleurs du ppe parti
populaire européen vous avez été élu
pour l'ump alors que pensez vous de ceux
de ce plan juncker est ce que je
reprends ma question est ce que c'est un
remède miracle ou un mirage qui ne
trompe personne
non c'est ni un mirage ni une recette
miracle
l'europe a été souvent vue comme une
contrainte comme voilà aujourd'hui avec
le plan humain coeur c'est on parle de
projet on parle d'investissements
on parle de croissance donc c'est une
bonne chose que la commission européenne
très méditative
je pense que c'est une bonne chose parce
que c'est une une vraie différence c'est
un vrai changement c'est une volonté
politique qui aujourd'hui affirmer de
dire l'europe dans le contexte mondial
doit investir dont investir dans des
contraintes avec l'europe a été vu
souvent sur des contraintes budgétaires
aujourd'hui c'est un projet
d'investissement et on parle ici d'un
investissement privé finalement il n'y a
rien de fixé puisque l'europe l'union
européenne va contribuer qu'à hauteur
d'une vingtaine de milliards d'euros
elle compte sur les investisseurs privés
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils peuvent
répondre à l'appel de la commission
qu'est ce qui les pousserait à investir
en europe
le plongeon coeur ses 315 milliards
l'europe mais 21 milliards et l'objectif
c'est de dire quand un euro et mis sur
des projets qui sont labellisés par
l'europe qu'ils sont
valider des hommes des partenaires
privés viennent mettre 15 euros
globalement sur des programmes européens
le projet a fonctionné donc par exemple
sur quoi est ce que vous avez il y a
plusieurs projets sur la banque
européenne d'investissement à lever
plusieurs milliards d'euros sur le même
système de
l'effet multiplicateur 1 x 15 il ya eu
des programmes sur les pme c'est un
projet qui va fonctionner une bonne
méthode c'est une volonté par jean il
est aujourd'hui si vous regardez
l'europe les taux sont faibles
il a de l'argent en europe donc
mécaniquement le projet va fonctionner
ça repose sur la confiance et ça repose
sur une volonté politique qui
aujourd'hui qui fonctionne est ce que
vous pensez à des grands projets très
concrets par exemple dans les transports
ou dans l'énergie qui pourrait rentrer
dans le cadre de ce plan de jean claude
juncker les priorités ils ont été
affirmés clairement c'est le numérique
l'écologie le vert les transports donc
il ya aujourd'hui sur 315 milliards
il ya 700 milliards de projets déposés
ah oui déposez qui sont aujourd'hui
devant la commission
donc ça veut dire que le plan est
crédible et que ensuite quatre quoi
faire il ya de quoi faire dire quoi
faire et l'europe voilà voilà il ya 700
milliards de projets déposés alors on va
parler d'un autre homme qui est à la une
cette semaine david cameron le premier
ministre britannique a annoncé de
nouvelles mesures pour limiter davantage
l'accès aux aides sociales des immigrés
venus de l'union européenne écouter
si vous êtes de l'union européenne et
que vous venez en grande-bretagne à la
recherche d'un emploi nous ne paierons
pas votre chômage si vous restez pendant
plus de six mois sans travailler vous
rentrerez chez vous si vous travaillez
et vivait en grande bretagne vous ne
disposerez pas davantage sociaux de
logements sociaux et du crédit d'impôt
vous n'aurez pas tout cela tant que vous
n'aurez pas participer au système
pendant quatre ans
non ce n'est pas la première fois que
david cameron ne tient ce genre de
propos mais est ce que cette fois des
mots très durs quand même très très
franc est ce qu'il n'est pas allé trop
loin selon vous mhadjou david cameron va
trop loin
de manière générale il a trop de manière
générale j'ai trop loin il court après
le équipe après les europhobes qui s'ils
agissaient au parlement européen le
youki petit demande parti qui dit qu'il
s'agissait au parlement et qui demande
la sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne
globalement qu'est ce que dit cameron il
dit il faut aussi je moi je suis
français je viens en angleterre il faut
je réside depuis quatre ans pour pouvoir
avoir un logement social pour pouvoir
prétendre à des droits donc ça c'est
discrimination une remise en cause
profonde de la libre circulation au sein
de l'union européenne il ya deux sujets
l'immigration bien sûr c'est un sujet il
ya l'immigration extra européenne qui
est un sujet d'avis qu'à vendre mais la
libre en cause la libre circulation au
sein de l'union européenne
il court après l'équipe mais là d'un
autre côté il dit et si je ne suis pas
écouter ce sera comme ça je veux
remettre en cause la libre circulation
et si je ne suis pas écouté et bien dans
ce cas le royaume uni pour un très bon
pourra très bien sortir de l'union
européenne après le référendum qu'il
compte organiser est ce que si le
royaume s il met sa menace à exécution
ce sera un problème pour l'europe que le
royaume y soit en l'angleterre a déjà un
pied dedans un pied dehors
elle est dans l'union est là pas la
monnaie il faut leur quelques a choisi
re moi je suis convaincu en tout cas
c'est je pense que beaucoup souhaitent
il faut une clarification la grande
bretagne a vocation à être bien sûr dans
l'europe et dans le sur des sujets
simples bien sûr l'économie sur la
défense l'installation nucléaire sur la
défense il ya la défense européenne
n'existe pas ceci dit la dissuasion
nucléaire qui est un sujet dont on parle
peu mais qui est un vrai sujet repose
aujourd'hui sur la france et la grande
bretagne
donc la france a intérêt à ce que le
royaume uni reste rassure mais en
algérie cameron court après le clip
alors juste un dernier mot pour finir
sur un sujet qui fait parler à
strasbourg les députés ont voté pour le
démantèlement de google à une très large
majorité ce que c'est un vote symbolique
ou est-ce que la guerre est déclarée
entre google et les institutions
européennes il n'y a pas de bière
déclaré il ya simplement une volonté
politique qui est affirmée de la part du
parlement vers la commission j'ai dire
une chose très simple
google c'est le moteur de recherche on
utilise tous est ce que google doit être
profite de sa situation de recherche
pour faire du commerce
ça c'est la question n'est dans les
faits est ce que les institutions
européennes ont les moyens que des par
le passé il ya eu un vrai conflit entre
l'union européenne et microsoft en 2013
l'union européenne a mis 500 millions sa
table de deux contraintes d'amendé
finalement c'est donc dans les dix ans
qui viennent il ya un sujet entre
l'union européenne et google eh bien on
en reparlera très sûrement merci marc
joulaud d'avoir été l'invité de cette
émission place tout de suite à la
deuxième partie dehors des dodos la
france compte 74 députés parmi eux de
nombreux députés du front national
il siège comme non inscrit puisqu'ils
n'ont pas de groupe alors est-ce une
arme est impuissante ou au contraire une
délégation importante voyez ce reportage
signé jeremy hartmann et georgia
beaucourt
non parce que ça doit qu'à l'endroit où
on a eu la conférence de paston jours
ils ont investi le parlement européen
mais sont parfois encore un peu perdus
ici mais je me repère beaucoup mieux à
strasbourg qu'à bruxelles
c'est un peu de mal marie christine
arnautu fait partie de ces 23 députés du
front national que les français ont
envoyé en juin dernier dans cette
institution
alors nous sommes au sixième ici
attention par vous cognez parce que ces
petits ici à la malle et frappe en ce
temps-là mal celle là vous la trouverez
dans tous les bureaux des députés
c'est la malle qui fait l'aller retour
entre bruxelles et strasbourg à dompter
les toilettes à cette europe froide
bureaucratique qu'il dénonce si souvent
ils la découvrent maintenant de
l'intérieur mais pénale que nous soyons
ici à ben strasbourg où que nous soyons
à bruxelles à aucun moment nous perdons
de vue que nous avons été élus en france
par des français qui n'ont fait que nous
mandaté ici au parlement européen pour
tenir parole et pour respecter notre
profession de foi que nous avions fait
envers eux pendant la campagne des
européennes
une mission que marie christine arnautu
s'applique à remplir avec le plus grand
sérieux en approuve devant notre caméra
est un et les dany soir est elle
toujours aussi consciencieuse et assis
nu ce jour là en tout cas leurs députés
fn se montre particulièrement
pointilleuse pour préparer son
intervention dans l'hémicycle le conte
sur l'immigration clandestine en
méditerranée les miens vue de mieux
gérer les flux migratoires en réalité il
nie comme chaque député européen
elle n'aura droit qu'à une minute de
temps de parole un chronométrage
s'impose aujourd'hui en italie sur douze
centres d'identification et d'expulsion
huit ont été fermées à cause des
révoltes de clandestins
la situation est explosive et monsieur
salvini l'a dit les italiens subissent
l'arrivée de 150 à 160 mille migrants
illégaux
marie christine arnautu
une députée comme une autre pas tout à
fait elle est en réalité considéré
officiellement comme députés non
inscrits
car les élus front national n'ont
toujours pas réussi à former deux
groupes parlementaires et se plaignent
de ne pas avoir les mêmes droits que
certains le fait de ne pas avoir deux
groupes fait que dans les commissions
thématiques l'occurrence moi je sais la
commission des transports et du tourisme
nous n'avons pas de coordinateur c'est à
dire en gros nous n'avons pas de
représentant officiel du groupe
et donc nous avons moins de moins de
temps de parole ou moins de possibilité
de déposer des amendements pour former
un groupe
le règlement impose un minimum de 25
députés et sept nationalités
pour l'instant le front national n'a
convaincu que quatre autres d italien de
la ligue du nord aux autrichiens du fps
mais marine le pen refusé de s'allier
avec d'autres partis à la réputation
encore plus sulfureuses comme les néo
nazi grec dogdoré où les ultra
nationaliste hongrois du jeu big
certains députés frontistes n'ont pas la
même retenue
je pense qu'il y à des forces politiques
qui sont représentés dans ce parlement
que je ne vais pas détailler mais dont
on dit du mal qui sont diabolisés
personnellement personnellement ses
opinions personnelles
ce n'est pas l'opinion de la présidente
et je joue collectif
je souhaiterais que l'on s'entende avec
tous ceux qui partagent nos opinions sur
l'europe minoritaire dans l'hémicycle
incapable de former un groupe
parlementaire les vingt-trois députés fn
ressemble pour l'instant à une arme est
impuissante
ils ont vendu du vent aux français en
disant voté pour nous et vous allez voir
ça va déménager à bruxelles et à
strasbourg
en réalité ça déménage rien du tout et
en fait ils ne font que que s'auto
alimenter l ça sert en fait à rien
malheureusement effet ça fait surtout
pas avancer la vie quotidienne des gens
une situation de blocage que le leader
historique du fn préfère minimiser
on est député on assiste on vote a
débuté socialement ça vote
est ce une opposition qui est
minoritaire ce qui quand même
relativement banal dans une assemblée
derrière de ne défendre nos idées avec
la mesure des moyens qui nous ont été
données par nos électeurs il n'empêche
si les élus du front national n'arrive
pas à obtenir les mêmes droits que les
députés inscrits dans des groupes
parlementaires
certains menacent déjà de saisir la cour
de justice de l'union européenne
le front national au parlement européen
on en parle avec deux députés qui nous
ont rejoints sur ce plateau sophia in't
veld bonjour vous venez des pays-bas
vous êtes membre du groupe adl qui
regroupe notamment les démocrates et
centristes et vous êtes ancienne
présidente de la commission des lois ici
au parlement et en face de vous marc
tarabella
bonjour vous êtes belge fait parti des
socialistes européens
on a voulu voir ce regard croisé de
votre part sur sur cette délégation de
députés fn qui est donc la plus
importante pour la france mais qui n'a
pas de groupe sauf ya une vérité ce que
les députés fn sont des députés comme
les autres où est-ce qu'ils ont une
place à part ici au parlement mais nous
sommes tous des députés ego il n'y a pas
de différence mais je crois j'ai vu un
peu le vidéo tout à l'heure dans une
démocratie et je crois que l'essentiel
c'est pas comme le disait monsieur le
pen tout simplement voter tout le temps
c'est faire des compromis
trouver des majorités pour ses idées on
ne peut pas il dit il défend ses idées
mais pourquoi il n'est pas capable de
convaincre les autres parce que c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne dans une
démocratie on cherche des compromis
on cherche des majorités on cherche le
consensus marc tarabella en france il ya
beaucoup de déclarations tonitruantes de
la part de certains leaders du front
national ici on a l'impression qu'ils
sont plus calmes quel est votre
sentiment à vous et ce qu'ils auront ils
se sont faits au fonctionnement européen
de l'europe comme l'a dit sophie in't
veld chaque député
nous sommes tous égaux entre nous et on
a les moyens de travailler le travail
s'effectue non seulement en plénière
mais bien en amont bien avant dans les
commissions parlementaires dans les
groupes et c'est là que se forgent
décision là les voiliers voulais vous
parler avec dorna qui sont présents
marché de la commission agriculture ils
sont souvent présents et actifs
tout le contraire de leur chef de file
marine le pen qui il faut le rappeler
entre 2009 et 2014 a été membre la
commission emploi elle n'y a jamais mis
les pieds alors c'est une manière de
travailler et de faire du vent comme le
disait josé bové d'aller partout aux
côtés des travailleurs qui sont victimes
de délocalisations d'entreprises ou bien
de concurrence déloyale avec des
ouvriers qui viennent d'ailleurs et
moins cher avec le dumping social qui
est qui sévit malheureusement on le
connaît aussi en belgique mais de ne pas
venir de la commission où on a
possibilité de faire changer
nous c'est grave c'est de faire croire
qu'on est aux côtés des gens mais en
fait on ne travaille pas dans leur
intérêt
ça c'est exactement la caricature de
marine le pen vous dites qu'il faut pas
mettre tout les députés les élus du fn
dans le même panier c'est là qu'il
débute des élus qui ont reçu l'aval du
peuple
ils sont là pour travailler il y en a
qui vont certainement s'impliquer tant
mieux c'est le rôle ils doivent bien ça
aux citoyens et puis jeudi le mauvais
exemple dans leur groupe est donnée par
le chef de file marine le pen qui ne
travaillent pas mentalement et présente
trois jours par mois à strasbourg fait
du foin est sur le plateau de télévision
invite monsieur salvini par ailleurs et
xénophobe puant dans ce parlement le
salvini elle refuse de faire alliance
avec avec d'autres ça on les juge
salvini et quand même à xénophobe quasi
digne d'autres extrémistes du jobbik par
exemple on oubliera lequel refuse tout
sauf à une telle dette d'accord avec
cette analyse de votre collègue marc
tarabella qui dit qui est un peu un
double visage un double jeu le problème
c'est que d'un côté on ne peut pas
exclure des députés parce qu'ils
appartiennent à une partie autres en
même temps ils doivent être obliger à
participer dans le processus
démocratique et il se refuse c'est ça le
problème créé pour eux le temps de faire
ses courses parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
n'ont pas moi juste m'a personnellement
je peux vous dire que je suis prêt à
travailler avec chaque collègue qui est
prête à participer dans le premier
compréhension du front national écoutez
mais on travaille sur base des idées moi
je n'ai jamais été favorable à des
cordons sanitaires des trucs comme ça
mais ils ne se prennent pas au sérieux
eux mêmes s'ils veulent vraiment acheter
quelque chose pour leurs électeurs
ils doivent être prêts à faire des
compromis et à chercher des majorités
comme tout le monde parce que moi aussi
moi en tant que centriste libéral moi
aussi je dois faire des compromis avec
les partis de gauche les partis de
droite c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
fonctionne dans une démocratie et je
crois pas qu'ils achètent beaucoup pour
les citoyens qui ont mis confiance en
eux s'il s'ils ne participent pas il
reste là à crier ils sont
à côté du jeu il fait font beaucoup de
fracas mais il a chiffré chef
strictement rien il faut 25 députés
venus de sept pays différents c'est le
règlement du parlement européen pour
faire un groupe pour l'instant le front
national ne les a pas est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils qui peut avoir ce groupe
au sein du parlement européen bientôt
ils pourraient mais je trouve normal que
le parlement ait une règle claire vous
savez nous sommes 7 151 députés venant
de 28 pays
des règles ont cinquante partis
nationaux représentés au parlement
européen à peu près qu'il faut pas
changer cette règle on wheels on va la
changer parce que si vous voulez que le
parlement soit un foutoir il faudrait
que deux trois personnes puissent faire
un groupe
or ici il y a sept groupes politiques de
la gauche on va dire extrême et la
gauche radicale jusqu'à la droite
radicale
il ya sept groupes politiques il
pourrait y avoir un huitième mais ils
peuvent rien à voir 25 août rend ce
serait une cacophonie permanente
or il est quand même normal qu'une
assemblée s'organise pour que les
travaux puissent se faire évoluer vers
des compromis nécessaires personnes et
majorité à lens parlement il faut
toujours se parler entre différents
groupes pour arriver à des compromis les
plus larges possibles et donc il est
normal qu'ils aient cette règle de
limitation de création groupe
c'est une contrainte c'est pas pour
exclure des députés mais il faut bien
comprendre qu'on donne des moyens du
parlement européen a un goût pour faire
le travail ici au sein du parlement
européen
un nouveau panneau inscrits il a plus
d'argent et que surtout il attend de
parole non les ans il ya de plus 50 ans
parole est proportionnelle aux ordres de
personne il ya 50 ans inscrits ou une
quarantaine de 1045 d'inscrits ils ont
un temps de parole au prorata de leur
importance relative au parlement donc la
royauté si l'on compte
oui si on travaille sur un sujet disons
nous on travaille ensemble dans la
commission des droits de femmes par
exemple si je fais des négociations au
nom de mon groupe avec monsieur therabel
au nom de son groupe je sais très bien
qu'il ya 180 députés derrière lui mais
je peux pas négocier avec chaque chacun
des députés a individuellement ça
fonctionne pas concède donc qui
sentirait risque d'entendre des
compromis parce que ça fonctionne pas
comme ça
nationale pas non plus alors je vous
propose d'entendre ce que dit un de vos
collègues députés européens le français
jean arthuis au sujet du front national
c'est très court et explicite écouter
ils sont à l'indicateur de la déception
populaire un indicateur du
dysfonctionnement la gouvernance
publique c'est tellement commode pour un
chef d'état pour un chef de gouvernement
de s'essuyer les pieds sur le paillasson
européen
marc tarabella est ce que cette
stratégie qui se consiste à dire si ça
ne va pas c'est la faute de l'europe le
paillasson européen et c est ce que ca
de l'avenir de cette genre tu as raison
sont halal istres écho aux propos très
très clair que effectivement remettre la
faute de tous les maux sur le dos de
l'europe l'europe est certainement
responsable par une dérive de certaines
politiques de problèmes créés à la
résolue aussi beaucoup de problèmes
une solution serait de dire qu'ils
s'essuient les pieds sur le paillasson
oui c'est un peu un peu vie mais c'est
vrai on s'enorgueillit peut-être de
politiques qui sont des réussites et
quand ya une contrainte on dit c'est de
la faute de l'europe c'est de la faute
de bruxelles du tout dans tous les pays
d'europe non en belgique on dit pape
c'est bruxelles tout le monde est à
bruxelles il ya de ça maintenant il est
clair aussi que le front national comme
d'autres partis populistes d'extrême
droite sort sur le mal être des gens sur
la crise économique et non pas de
solution faut croire qu'ils ont des
solutions et ainsi pouvoir monter leur
cote de popularité dans la population
alors les élus eurofor d'extrême droite
dont le fn et les italiens du mouvement
des cinq étoiles de beppe grillo ont
déposé une motion de censure contre la
nouvelle commission juncker elle a été
rejetée mais les tout de même est ce que
ça ne risque pas de créer un précédent
elle a quand même été présenté avec
cette alliance institué pour l'occasion
personnellement je suis pas choqué c'est
la démocratie où l'on nous sommes dans
la nef mais honnêtement moi je je d'une
certaine façon je me réjouis même de la
présence de tous ces partis même de
l'extrême droite parce que ça rend le
parlement européen beaucoup plus
représentatif
parce que je me souviens il ya vingt ans
il y avait que deux grands groupes
politiques avec un petit groupe libéral
entre les deux maintenant c'est vraiment
la réflexion de l'électorat donc c'est
beaucoup plus et je voudrais ajouter
quelque chose à ce que disait monsieur
arrivant collègues de groupe c'est que
il faut pas accepter à 100% ce discours
que comment dire l'europe c'est le bouc
émissaire et tout ça parce qu'on voit
exactement le même discours le discours
identique aux états unis mais là il n'y
a pas de bruxelles comme comme bouc
émissaire mais là c'est contre
l'immigration peur de la mondialisation
peur de la perte d'identité nationale
donc c'est un peu le même discours là on
a le tea party
on a la même stagnation politique la
même paralysie politique donc c'est un
peu il ya un problème plus grand c'est
que les gens ont peur de tous les
développements il on sait la crise
économique ça n'a rien à voir avec
toutes les fautes l'union européenne la
marque par rapport à la mention sont
sûrs ils ont fait la preuve de tout leur
inutilité dans ce parlement pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont le droit de le faire
ils l'ont fait mais quel est leur but
sept blocs et l'europe c'est que la
machine ne tourne plus et que les
décisions ne se prennent plus parce
qu'ils sont anti européen profondément
parce que je suis content d'être au
coeur
ce qui est choquant dans leurs dépôts de
motions ceux qui la font à peine dix
jours après ce que monsieur juncker et
toute sa commission et commencer à
travailler
une hausse on censure elle sert à
peut-être sanctionner une commission qui
ne travaillent pas qui fait des erreurs
c'est un coup d'éclat plus qu'un
véritable éclat et qui a renforcé le
soyons fiers parce que je signale que la
motion a été rejetée par plus de voix
que le nombre de voix qu'il a obtenu
pour se faire élire président de la
commission et sa commission votre train
aussi certains à le soutenir finalement
alors qu'il faudrait peut-être voulu
être critique sur cette affaire luc
slicks dont gm haussier avec mes amis
socialistes belges madame arena et
monsieur bayer nous avons signé la
demande d' enquête
mais bien sûr en dehors de cette motion
vise l abcès c'est un abcès fiscalité
dérégulé au niveau européen je suis très
contente d'apprendre ça parce que mon
groupe
le groupe libéral avait proposé une
commission denquête qui au début les
deux grands groupes ont dit oui très
bonne idée mais ils ont essayé à a
à l'enterrer un peu un faible rapport
docu sicilia de l'appui de votre groupe
pour les socialistes belges surtout
francophones sont les plus rebelles du
groupe socialiste donc voilà heurtaux
faire plaisir mais voilà j'ai confiance
dernière question sur tous ces partis
europhobes eurocritique eurosceptiques
est-ce qu'ils ont plus de différences
que de que deux points communs ce qu'il
faut craindre une lame de fond ici au
parlement
c'est clair que la difficulté qu'ils ont
mais ça c'est leur problème et je passe
surtout essayer de bimi cédant leur
problème c'est qu'ils ont des logiques
très différents qui sont purement
nationaliste donc sont arrangées avec
d'autres par exemple yuki britannique où
c'est encore autre chose ça c'est très
compliqué sont eux soient rentrées dans
leurs folles ils veulent la disparition
de l'europe sortir le royaume uni de
l'union européenne
pas de solution en face et caricatural
mais ce ne sont pas des il s'appelle
eurosceptiques ou europhobes mais c'est
pas vrai ils sont anti européen et
syphon soyons clairs pour les gens plus
ardue par la grande majorité de cette
partie et ses députés anti européens se
sont également d'excellents phoques des
racistes et antisémites et homophobes et
misogynes des nationalistes et aux puces
et yade il ya dix ans par les animaux
clés à des partis apparemment monsieur
gollnisch l'acceptent les partis qui
n'accepte plus le système démocratique
qui disent on a le droit d'utiliser la
violence pour imposer nos idées
politiques
oddo reste des nazis les lions d'asie ce
nazi monsieur gollnisch lui on vient de
s'allier avec eux les fachos stressant
mais ça semble c'est son souhait est
donc mais ils ont des distinctions entre
eux claire mais il ya quand même une
lame de fond qui les réunit c'est un
extrémisme de droite est assez
rebaissait l'europe à laquelle de
laquelle on a tourné la page
grâce à l'union européenne merci à vous
d'avoir été sur ce plateau on vous
laisse repartir dans l'hémicycle on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo cha cha
ouais